how to go and read my spirit back I just
wanted to make this quick video to say
thank you since we hit number one is so
awesome we're going to do a ton of cool
stuff to celebrate bubbles Smosh must
been here hey man hey man okay big
number low subscribe yeah awesome
but if you're going to be number one
most subscribed you're gonna need a
couple things yeah uh here's here's
something that you are definitely yeah
oh go Tigers man fabulous I feel
homeless oh me anymore though I look
fabulous you can't go without that ya
tiara and the scarf is the way to go
yeah oh I'm thinking would it feel a
little tropical you know you're need a
vacation
oh if you want to UM stay well hydrated
cross-selling you need crunch bling ya
know some good reading material oh this
one is great yeah that's my favorite
that's my favorite book so yeah that's
about you getting it yeah and this is in
case you need called cops you're
probably most likely needed call the
cops
frequently oh and uh once well snot ones
and that's about it right yeah I think
that's all oh wait there's one more
thing yeah yeah I almost forgot it's the
most important one yeah beautiful guy
yeah yeah oh it's on your cheek huh I'm
good at it I'm not that good at it
I feel ready now you're ready you're
ready go out there and get up yeah I'm
gonna fist
brofist oh but hey it doesn't wait
endlessly working you know really move
your head next ruin a perfect cute god
mm rest mine is pretty bad and something
incredible just happened if you don't
know what I'm talking about
the bras just became the most subscribed
channel on YouTube if someone told me
like two years ago when I started out
making videos then I would be number one
and actually people told me back then
but I would never have believed them and
not not even in my wildest dreams vote
for Pedro so it's just so surreal that
now
happen.i I can't even I can't even
believe in myself this journey that you
bros have been with me has been crazy
enough already but that things like this
happen is just too much it's too much
honestly a number shouldn't really
matter you know I think for anyone out
there on YouTube we all do it because we
enjoy doing it I'm really happy to be in
the situation where we can start huge
fundraisers like the water campaign for
example that makes me really proud and
that's what I want to keep making in the
future as well do I deserve to be number
one probably probably not I'm certainly
not complaining I just want to throw
that out there I know a lot of people
seem to think crude applies your best
but I'm pretty good okay well my kiddin
I'm [ __ ] awesome having anyone who
subscribed to my channel you you've been
part you're part of this and you're part
of making a a man's dream come true I
really hope that I can inspire other
people to dream big and like and work
hard to achieve their goals because yes
I might not be the one most deserving in
this position but I work really hard to
get here and that's because I love doing
it and that's why I'm gonna keep doing
it still just me I'm just one guy
editing and recording all these videos
probably I'm proud of that and I hope
that will inspire people pretty much
this is will be the ultimate brofist
supernova explosion something I don't
even know let's reach for the stars bras
we should pan out to live there I'd be
cheesy anyway stay awesome bros I know
you will